back here on the rich eyes and show the
reporter of MMA fighting calm and the
host of the MMA our podcast the MMA beat
is Ariel Helwani how are you Ariel so
here I am coming on your show wrist and
you're gonna take a shot at me in the
first 10 seconds you know you're here it
is that's just me that's me working it
out my own anger and angst at the Knicks
and you and and as you know I keep
telling you just move on
turn the page I know honestly the season
ended for me like two months ago one
sport think it's got injured I haven't
been able to watch a game it's very
depressing so I appreciate you reminding
me that she's still playing my apologies
so let's let's uh let's hit what what
went down at Brooklyn what is the
headline coming out of out of UFC 223
Ariel in your mind this is no hyperbole
rich but that was the craziest week in
the history of this sport and there's no
close second I'm still having a hard
time processing what happened between
Thursday around 1:30 p.m. Eastern Time
and Friday around 8 p.m. because the
thing is there were two gigantic stories
happening and unfolding simultaneously
and both were kind of unfolding in the
worst way possible for the UFC so on the
one hand you have the Conor McGregor
situation where McGregor flies in from
Dublin enters the Barclays Center tried
to find hubby beater magomayev who's in
that the headline headlining act for UFC
223 finds him in the loading dock of the
Barclays center he's in a bus McGregor
and his friends around 10 of them
attacked the bus throw a bunch of things
at the bus like like like chairs and a
dolly windows are broken two fighters
who are competing or scheduled compete
at 2:23 get injured as a result of you
know shattered glass hitting them they
get ruled out of the fight
McGregor and his team obviously don't
get on the bus they run away later on
that evening
McGregor turns himself in his friend
also turns himself in so that thing is
all unfolding and it's as surreal as it
gets and then come Friday morning the
UFC has this very important main event W
turmagar made off against max Holloway
which is the main event that was put
together on at that point
four days notice because the original
you know interim champion 20 Ferguson
got injured last week while tripping
over a cable while doing interviews on
Thursday of last week like that ended up
not even being the craziest part of this
whole you know situation at the so max
hallway steps up the federal HIV and
then he can't make way he gets ruled out
of the fight the UFC calls upon three
other fighters for various reasons they
can't take the fight and then finally
they settle on a guy named Ally Quinta's
was from Long Island local rocky story
he takes the fight on 24 hours notice
Connors been showing up in court I mean
the thing was just so surreal rich I
can't even put it to words I'm still
having a hard time digesting at all so
graphically what the headline is I guess
the biggest story to the masses is what
happened you know to Conor but it's
really these two sort of stories
happening simultaneously and us trying
to cover them both that's what I'll
remember from last week well I mean and
I'm trying to pick up what Dana White is
putting down in the video that we saw
first blush that was put out where I
guess he was being interviewed by
somebody in the bowels of Barclays
Center just after this incident with the
bus had happened and he looked beaten
upset and saying that he didn't want to
do business with Conor McGregor right
now and he used the phrase
right now three different times and then
later on on the weekend he's saying that
that other sports have seen a lot worse
so I'm kind of trying to figure out what
the spin is on this do you think what
happened with Conor McGregor has damaged
the sport in some way permanently area
so I'll first address your first point
cuz it's a great point thought that Dana
White Thursday Friday handled this as
well as possible he's in a tough spot we
recognize that they're not cutting Conor
McGregor he is the biggest star in the
history of this sport so he often has to
choose his words wisely when it comes to
McGregor and I thought he did a great
job of that I mean he was really upset
he said all the right things disgusted
all the stuff I mean it was very clear
that he was putting his foot down I
thought and then comes Saturday as you
said at the post-fight press conference
it seemed as though you know he kind of
took a step back and as you said he was
saying on another sports we've seen
worse I didn't think that that was as
good of a job I mean if you're gonna if
you're gonna say this is the most
disgusting act in the history of the
sport we're going to deal with this all
that stuff
you kind of have to stick with that for
at least a little more than 48 hours and
it seemed as though time filled that
wouldn't he he said that he spoke to
Conor and they're in a good place maybe
there was an agreement I don't know for
sure but it sounded much better than the
first time he said he spoke to him
agreement maybe that they wouldn't you
know speak very publicly negatively
about this I thought it was very
interesting that they released the
footage of what happened to UFC released
the footage now I know there's a lot of
people who would say ah you know that's
because this was planned that's because
you know the UFC was behind it no that's
not the case III think that the UFC felt
like they needed to put the cards out on
the table but in doing so they're kind
of incriminating him a little more so I
thought that that would make things
worse between Connor and the UFC he says
that they're in a good spot we'll see
what happens Connor Connor kind of goes
to the beat of his own drum but but like
if you're expecting you know Connor to
come back and fight now in May or June
he can't he's in he's involved in this
situation I think at the end of the day
they'll figure it out
thankfully no one was seriously hurt but
there's a long road ahead here because
you know there's there's the next
hearing on June 14th a bunch of Fighters
were affected they may sue him as well
knows about the employees who were so
there's all kinds of things up in the
air but it was very interesting at least
to me that Dana softened his stance I
didn't expect him to do that 48 hours
later Ariel Helwani the best in the
business Joyner is here on the Rich
Eisen show after UFC 223 and then Ronda
Rousey takes the stage last night in her
wrestling debut and rave reviews all
over the place with her saying that
she's glad she lost her last two in the
Octagon because it it allowed her to get
to this point where she's now a
wrestling star I mean how does that sit
with uh with the UFC world do you think
Ariel so rich III could do two hours on
this story because I think Ronda Rousey
has put up a blueprint for every athlete
Under the Sun every celebrity Under the
Sun on how to best not deal with you
know some kind of setback in your career
some kind of failure in your career she
couldn't have handled those two losses
worse it has been astounding to me how
poorly she has handled these losses
every step of the way every chance that
she has gone to at least just talk about
the fight she hasn't even talked about
the losses she has
not I have not heard the word Holly home
come out of her mouth and that was two
losses ago she ran away from it all and
look I don't know what she's going
through mentally I don't know I've never
been in her shoes but I have also seen
other athletes falter quote unquote
choke you know not reach the finish line
on the grandest stage as possible I've
seen Conor lose on the grandest stage
possible and I've seen him show up to
the press conference with a nice suit on
and handle it you know as well as
possible Conor part of the blueprint how
to handle loss she put out the blueprint
how not to handle loss and so it is
refreshing you know a year and a half
later from the second loss two and a
half years after the first loss that she
finally actually says these people's
name but she looks like she's turning
the page I'm happy for she did great
last night it's time to move on but I
just think it's amazing to me I saw her
do that car wash with ESPN two weeks ago
she can't even say the word MMA she has
all this resentment towards MMA the
reality is she wouldn't be in
Wrestlemania if it wasn't for her stint
as a UFC superstar the reality is that
no one would care about her if she
didn't you know do what she did in the
UFC so why do you have all this
resentment you know you lost everyone
loses we go through way worse things in
life we get sick we have deaths and a
family it's hard to feel sorry for
someone who just lost and made millions
of dollars and I don't think she
recognizes that so she's handling it in
her own way I'm happy she spoke to
Ramona Shelburne I'm happy she said the
things that she said it's time to move
on but you can't undo the last two and a
half years to not even address it once
and not speak to the MMA media and make
us feel like we're bad people just
because we want to talk to you about a
single loss in your career to me is
mind-blowing but you know everyone's
different everyone's gonna handle their
things differently so tell me Ariel I
mean what what is what is the future
here and I want to give the macro view
here to make sure I get it all out
because any time we talk UFC on this
show brockman you could back me up here
it's extremely popular the video click
set cetera et cetera direct the metrics
are are better than most sports no
question about it that said you could
say the three most famous MMA fighters
right now that that have name
recognition one just debuted in the WWE
last night one got let out in Hancock
and is who knows when the heck he's
gonna fight again in Conor McGregor
another is John Jones right bones Jones
we all know what's going on with him
when is the MMA gonna have somebody
that's known for fighting in the MMA and
it's somebody that you could go in and
see and and follow and be excited about
aerial it hasn't been a very good
stretch
it's amazing ever since you know the
Fertitta brothers sold the company
they've had an amazing string of bad
luck but I do feel this is kind of and
I'm not gonna equate it to my beloved
Knicks because they don't know how to
rebuild full-circle look could you go in
full circle
but the problem is the Knicks don't know
how to rebuild they've been rebuilding
for 20 years the UFC is actually
rebuilding quite nicely that they do
have some stars and by the way none
bigger than khabib nurmagomedov he may
not be a household name I know his name
is a little difficult for you know
people on this side of the pond to
pronounce but he is a megastar in his
home country of Russia he cannot go
outside without people swarming him he's
26 in oh now he finally got the
lightweight title on Saturday he his
trash talk is unbelievable it's very
much like triple G if you're familiar
with the way triple G talk it's sort of
that you know Eastern European broke in
English but it's very compelling when he
speaks and he's actually a better trash
talker than triple G he's the most
dominant force in the sport right now
and you know if we were able to weather
this storm of last Thursday the biggest
fight the UFC can make in the history of
the sport is Habib versus Connor they
both fight in the same weight class so
we've just got the belt that Conor was
stripped of I mean Connor flew from
Ireland to try to find this man I mean
there is a storyline there that every W
wishes they could think of if they could
somehow find a way to get these two men
to fight each other it would do two
million pay-per-views at the least in my
opinion so there are good things coming
they've got a TV deal coming up of
course Ronda is gone
John Jones in my opinion will come back
sooner than expected maybe even at the
end of this year and hey there are talks
if they have a deal in place with Brock
lesner and wouldn't that be crazy that
he'd be going now from WV to UFC so it's
not all doom and gloom it's a bit of a
rebuilding time but I don't think that
you know as the great New York Knick
guard Michael Ray Richardson once said
I'd be thinking I don't
the ship is sinking as much as people
want to make it seem real great uh
that's a that's a great one like that
right that's a great walk off that's a
great walk off ish if I didn't have one
more question okay what do you what did
you make of Mayweather saying if you
were on retires he comes to the Octagon
would you make of that you've heard of
Yogi Berra right I'm assuming you've
heard of this man Yogi Berra Yankee
catcher yes sir
he once said it's deja vu all over again
and that's what I think of when I think
of this story it's unfolding the same
way last year story unfolded except this
time he's talking about the UFC
it started with us saying get out of
here Floyd we want nothing to do with
you this is not happening the the
McGregor fight and then there's a video
and then there's an interview with Jim
Gray it's like the same thing all over
again almost the exact same time frame
it's unbelievable and now he's sitting
there talking about you know fighting on
145 and UFC my initial reaction was UFC
is in a contract year they need buzz
they need stars buff we were just
talking about just Floyd talking about
the possibility of going to the UFC is
great for them it's worth more than gold
for them but the more this thing unfolds
how can I say that it's not gonna happen
when we saw the impossible happened last
year it's bizarre to me I cannot think
of a valid reason why in the world he
would do this in my opinion he stands to
make more money as a boxer which is you
know the sport that you can arguably say
he's one of the greatest of all time
he's 50 you know he's 41 years old why
in the world would you transition to
this other sport that you know nothing
about that you stand to get embarrassed
maybe even seriously hurt and not even
make as much money as in the sport that
you're the best at it makes zero sense
to me whatsoever no Floyd has been a
great businessman over the years just
this keeping himself in the news is
great business for him
I can't say that it's not gonna happen
Dan I'm saying that they're in talks and
so again it's like yogi said deja vu all
over again it's literally unfolding the
exact same way with the same players
involved I would be shocked if it you
know actually comes to fruition but and
by the way just for the record I want to
see Connor Frye's Labib I want to see
Connor fight the best in MMA I'm tired
of the greatest in our sport at least
the biggest face in our sport you know
dabbling with this other stuff it's
great that you make money doing this but
it was cool to see Jordan in a White Sox
uniform but in the end we wanted to see
you back at the bulls uniform and
other stuff doesn't help Connors legacy
so I'd love it if he gets one fight
under his belt and then baby goes down
this road before if he's really you know
desperate to do so but the Floyd thing
isn't going away and I just can't
believe what we're talking about this
silly aerial great stuff is always
really appreciated I know you're busy
man don't you know court reporting and
reporting as you have done in the last
we believable thanks to the time thank
you right you got at Ariel Helwani
reporter for MMA fighting calm on SB
nation and then check out his MMA hour
podcast host of the MMA beat here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience